so i'm going to talk about using go for
the past two years in production
and all right so i'm travis reader the
cto and co-founder of iron il
uh we're the creators of iron mq and
ironworker
uh we basically have a platform for all
your asynchronous and background
processing
uh check it out www.iron.org
so first i'm going to talk about how we
decided on go how we got to that
point so when we first started we wrote
ironworker as a consulting company to
scratch our own itch with data
processing and
the consulting company we're doing ruby
on rails because if you're doing
consulting a couple years ago that was a
pretty hot thing to do and
people paid you for it so that's how it
got built in the first place
so when we were running our api service
most of us talked to about the api
service
uh for the high performance stuff we
would try to keep our
server loaded about 50 or less there's a
reason for that that i'll get too
when it increased beyond that we've
launched four servers and
and that's fine if you have a lot of
money to spend without being a startup
we didn't have a lot of money
this is how i thought the amazon
so the bigger problem wasn't really the
money it was actually the traffic spikes
when we had uh spikes and traffic on our
apis
a couple of the servers would like spike
up to 100 for no apparent reason
and when the server hits 100 it becomes
unresponsive
so when it's unresponsive the load
balancer takes it offline spreads load
across the rest of the servers
which you know adds more load to those
so it's a domino effect more load more
servers become unresponsive
more service taken offline so on and so
on until you're completely down
service going up and down off the load
balancer
we like to refer to this as a colossal
cluster
technical term this is that phenomenon
visualized
once server goes down the low is
distributed to the other ones inevitably
more and more servers keep going going
down
so we had two options either spend more
money
or rewrite it and we decided to rewrite
it
so choosing a language um we reviewed
a bunch of different languages we
reviewed all the other dynamic languages
see if we could do something fast like
python node
we looked at java and other derivatives
i come from a
long java background so that was that
was on the table but i really didn't
want to get into it
then we looked at go and ended up
choosing it
and here's why uh concurrency being a
fundamental part of language was huge
for us
uh there's other concurrency modules for
java and whatnot like
java.util.concurrency but
go being so core was really nice
the core library had almost everything
we need we didn't need to depend enough
too much on
other libraries i think we used maybe
two other
open source libraries one was for a
database driver another one was for
routing
uh it's tourist language like sydney was
saying
you know sort of feels like a dynamic
language
compiles compiles fast runs fast and
it's fun to write it
sort of like ruby and google is behind
it that was a
another big decision point so
you didn't consider erlang we
sort of did
because we've heard aws is all written
in the early and stuff so go back one
slide before you chose
yeah so yeah
what was the part of that picture i mean
erlang's decision was it came up
we didn't do that
but we didn't dig into it too much i
mean we wanted to use something that
uh you know our team had some experience
in or
you know so
so back when we chose go wasn't even go
one yet
um so it was pretty risky decision there
wasn't a big community
there wasn't a lot of open source
libraries there was
no success stories that i could think of
and we weren't sure if we could get
talent that was that was another big
factor
we were one of the first companies to
publicly say we're using it in
production
and the first people opposed to go job
job posting on the go nuts mailing list
that was the response but we did it
anyway
i wrote a blog post by this and a lot of
it was on hacker news a bunch of people
asked the same questions why do you use
this language is that so
why not python um
various reasons it's not as fast not
compiled so it's more error prone
the indentation based coding not a big
fan of
i feel like it wasn't a big enough step
forward
and if you look at benchmarks this is uh
go versus python on the
benchmarks game site i don't know if you
guys have seen this
but for more than half the tesco is 30
times faster so
and less memory
why not node uh there's one word
response to this
that's about all you need to know
so even though javascript v8 is actually
very fast surprising well not
surprisingly but
in some cases it beats go and it's not
too far off in most of them
it's because it's pc but it's still
javascript
you could see yeah
so why not jabber derivative i already
sort of answered this
i wrote job for a long time and i just
you know i just didn't want to go back
into it after using
newer languages like review and whatnot
uh and goal is a lot more interesting
and exciting
even though java is still faster than go
this is the uh
go versus java benchmark uh java beats
it
in most cases but uh you know not by too
much
and the memory consumption goes much
better
probably because no jbm though
why not ruby uh somebody said why don't
you just optimize ruby don't use rails
that would have been a really smart
decision actually but
it just wasn't enough the performance of
ruby's
it's on the worst end of the scale this
is go versus ruby
this first line here is 186 times faster
on that test
and as you can see you know orders of
magnitudes faster and a lot less memory
so we wanted a big jump a big gain and
something exciting to go with it
so after switching to go this is as soon
as we rolled it out
basically rewrote our api servers and go
you know following the exact same uh
api and whatnot and we reduced our
server count from 30 to two
like the same day uh second one was
purely just for redundancy we're barely
using the servers
and we never had a colossal cf again
ever oh
so performance has been uh i was told
that performance has been uh
stellar we've never had performance
issues on our api servers never had to
you know really dig deep in to go to
optimize it for anything
um we still to this day around two to
four
servers ish for uh our apis
right a lot more for our background
processing and whatnot but uh
and these servers can handle up to 300
million requests a day we've hit
uh bottleneck's always been something
else database or
other services we rely on
memory there's no virtual machine so
ghost starts really
fast and small which i'm sure a lot of
you are aware of
our flagship product iron pew starts up
in 6.5 mags
and that includes making all the
connections setting everything up and it
starts up almost instantly
and two years in we've never had a
memory leak or problems related to
memory
we're not talking huge machines here
uh concurrency again i'll bring this up
four part of the language the high level
constructs
like go routines and channels for
communicating between the go routines
are just killer as i'm sure you all know
and uh go routines they're they're kind
of the mix between
threads and unlocking io so you get the
best of uh
of node type stuff as well as the
threading and
java and no callbacks
another reference to javascript
reliability this is a bit hard to
quantify but
i feel like everything else we write if
we write it in ruby and other things
you're always a little bit scared to you
know press the deploy button
things like that but with our go
applications they're always pretty
confident that
it's going to work basically if it
compiles you know you feel pretty
confident that it's going to work
but you don't feel that way you get
scared to edit a dynamic language code
to push it out you get run time errors
you know we rarely ever have issues
after we roll out our go code
and the code tends to be a lot cleaner
and higher quality because
what the strict compiler is nice go
formats nice
um the compiler where you can't have
extra variables that you're not using it
forces you to remove them
and you can do a lot with a small amount
of code
i think all these things lead to better
reliability
deployment since go compiles into a
single
static binary deployment as simple as
throwing that on a server and starting
it up
no dependencies you don't have to worry
about dependencies being upgraded behind
the scenes or anything like that
and for us the item q binary is only six
mags
total
rolling back just as easy start stop the
one you're running and
start up the previous one you don't have
to worry about again dependencies being
upgraded
behind your back or anything like that
talent this one's a interesting one when
we first started
a couple years ago there was like
i don't know if anybody had been using
go in production so it was more people
just wanted to learn but even after we
posted our first uh
job postings we started getting people
you know phds from top
tech companies that even people from
google working on the adwords team just
wanting to work
with us just so they could work on go so
if you're ever considering it for that
purpose you can find talent easily
so anyway in conclusion we took a risk
it paid off
um you guys are all here because you
also believe the same thing
we love the language love this back
there's a lot of other companies using
it now i'm sure
i don't know how many people in this
room are using it now hands up for who's
using it in production
yeah i mean that's night and day
compared to a couple years ago
uh yeah so a couple final quotes i'll
leave you with
this is rob pike back in the early days
ago we realized that the kind of
software we built at google is not
always served well by the languages
we had available robert cannon myself
decided to make a language that would be
good for
writing the kinds of programs and right
at google and
i'm sure that's what we're all writing
now cloud cloud-based
apis and applications perfect for that
kind of stuff
derek callison about sarah who's the
upstairs guy ah
cool this is one of his quotes from wire
the management layers and infrastructure
layers of the newer technologies that
provide this cloud delivery model
within two years the majority will be
written and go and we're seeing this
more and more we're in a
heavy bit which is a cloud
startup sort of incubator type office
where there's a bunch of cloud service
providers and
you know more and more of these people
are using go to
to write their apis and do high
performance computing
google docs fail chromebooks
anyway so
thank you for listening that was a
presentation um
feel free to email me if you have any
questions anything like that and
i'll take questions right now too
anybody have any questions yep
go that's a good question
uh it's not necessarily i don't like it
but i find
this isn't really a dislike there's some
things like in
things like ruby that are a lot easier i
find myself still
scripting a lot in ruby stuff that
doesn't need to be high performance
i'll still use a language like ruby
because i
find you can do it quite a bit faster
but anything for high performance
these go yeah how big are your heaps and
gc pauses
after you launch it oh wow
um i don't have that information
handy but uh like i said it's never
we've
never had to optimize that kind of stuff
so
those would be ec2 largest for the most
part
anybody else
yeah so my impression of the ruby
community
focus a lot on testing how have you
approached
automated testing and use testing
so i mean we use go test but we also
going back to the ruby thing we have a
lot of tests written in ruby to test our
apis
so and we wrote a thing called abt
always be tested and it's actually
a thing that just constantly runs hits
our staging end production environments
runs like the full test suite all the
time kind of thing and
that's our ruby test suite which hits
you know every api endpoint and stuff
like that
anybody else cool cool
thank you
all right hey everyone my name is quinn
slack and i
am working on sourcecraft with beyond
who's in the audience
um just show of hands who has heard of
sourcecraft so far
okay a few people we have a long way to
go we're really new but
we're trying to make something super
useful for all of you and
want to talk about how we're building it
and then do some demos and show off a
cool tool we just made for all of you
personally tonight
so quick background source graph is
semantic code search
so we go and semantically analyze go
code in some other languages you can
search for
any function on github or bitbucket we
can show you usage examples and docs and
so on to see who uses your code
so check it out but i'll go into
some of the details of why we wanted to
do this
so the go philosophy is great it's like
if you follow a few of these conventions
that go set out in the very beginning
you get so much for free
you get code formatter doc generator
build tool test tool
you know go.org all of these things and
it's just if you agree to follow a few
conventions javascript
doesn't have that scala doesn't have it
java doesn't have it but go does
so you have these amazing tools that are
coming out and so our insight was
you know what more could we do for go
given that people have adopted these
conventions and
can we do the same thing for other
languages give people the same
you know amazing tool sets if they just
follow a few conventions
and we've you know we're a few months
into it
we're trying to make programming better
um in a bunch of different languages but
it's very early so let me show you what
we've done so far
so basically we want to semantically
analyze all the code and index it so
the first thing is start off with a
single package and go
it's actually super easy there's this go
types package how many of you have used
go types
okay not that many so another thing
that's amazing about go is it comes with
a built-in type checking library
other languages don't have that you have
to you know really rip the part the
compiler
and make it spit out information that it
was using just to generate bytecode
so what we do is we go through you know
all the code on on github you guys
already have and we
will iterate through the scopes after
semantically analyzing we'll go through
all the idents and ast
and just resolve each one of them to a
uri
so every function every local variable
that all of you have written
we've probably given it some unique
identifier in our system
so that's step one and the next thing is
we store all of this
just in a database we use postgres
obviously you could use anything
and uh you know we go through and then
every single of your go code files
every single character range we have
resolve to
whatever symbol it refers to so you know
you're calling a function then we say
from position 73 to 75 you're pointing
to the http handle
that's what we've done
and then one of the tools i'll be
showing off in just a second
is a tool that shows you for any
interface and go
uh all of the types that implement it
even in other repositories
even on you know github google code and
uh the reverse as well so we also go
through and all of these interfaces all
the types you guys have on github
we store this triple of info and then we
use that to query and find out
who implements a given type
so you know do all that analysis put in
the postgres
and do that for all the go repositories
out there we have something like
30 000 so far we're not there yet all
the way and then we've done it for a
bunch of other languages too
but that's the basic idea and uh you
know this guy dimitri came up and talked
about go
oracle it's a similar idea we actually
use
go types which go oracle's based on
we're just doing this in a larger scale
how can we bring to more people
and make it automatic
so i'll show you what it looks like
so we just want to see you know this hdb
handle function
probably all of you have used it what is
the docs and then how is it actually
used in other repositories
so let me make this bigger
because we've gone through and indexed
all of github we can find
all of these examples from other
projects and just let you see you know
how is this actually being used
in real life and it's annotated like
that
so it's a good way to find out how to
use code
you can find out who uses your code
because we've gone through and said you
know this person wrote this function
so you can go to your profile page it's
just sourcecraft.com
your github username and you can see all
these
cool stats uh you know show off
and then this is the tool that we built
just for all of you
tonight take any interface take any type
and find out
everything that implements that
interface or all the interfaces that
type
uh implements so here's responsewriter
which is how you return an http response
scroll down and we have these
implemented by 18 go types
and implements two go interfaces so if
you ever wondered like how do i use this
interface
you know there's no explicit source code
connection in go
that's part of the beauty of go but if
you need to know that then you can go to
source graph and check it out
and the reverse of that is given a type
what interfaces does it implement we can
do that too oh and
you know we've shown off the most
popular methods
essentially there so the
crypto tls con type implements all these
interfaces
and that just using the technique that i
showed just a few minutes ago
so that's what we have you can go around
and hope this tool is
useful spread it around and send us
feedback
any questions
yeah what other languages we have js
python and ruby and we have java in our
back pocket
not at least yet yep do you have any
plans to
allow people to get their proprietary
code
sort of introspective
yeah yeah we do that internally and
that's how we want to make money
eventually
i showed steps one through three and
four was profit but
we're not there yet
but if you are interested then come talk
to us
yes i i guess i wasn't
those are the actual types we use yeah i
mean we use go because we have a lot of
like
back end jobs we need to run a lot of
like shelling out to
you know python and so on and it's
really good also goes the inspiration
for sourcecraft
so so can you talk about a little bit
more about like
the differences the challenges that you
came through
like implementing for other languages
i wish that other languages had like a
you know python types package
we use whatever the best tools exist
already for the language we support
we're not going to write our own parser
and compiler
and stuff so you might have seen this
thing pi sonar
it was released recently we use that for
ruby
we ripped apart yard the dock generator
and it's a type entrance there and for
javascript we use
uh mariah haverbeck's uh turn
package but then there are a ton of edge
cases to handle and versioning
dependencies and so on
but we have uh some things that we'll
announce soon we have a pretty cool hire
we want to like push forward the state
of the art of type inference
so that we can do this really well we
can not only you know index the code
when you browse it but also do static
analysis to find
security issues you know potential
conflicts
and so on so we want to push this
forward
any other questions
all right